et d'angie je vous le disais en france
on s'est beaucoup moqué à l'époque de
l'assurance des autorités qui
considéraient que le nuage s'était
arrêté miraculeusement à nos frontières
petit à petit on le voit sur ces cartes
il a fallu se rendre à l'évidence la
contamination était bien arrivée sur
l'est le sud est de la france jusqu'en
corse une contamination aussi importante
que celle constatée dans les autres pays
européens exposés eux aussi au nuage de
tchernobyl alors quelles ont été les
conséquences sanitaires maintenant de ce
survol à la polémique fait toujours rage
et c'est le débat du 13
alors avec vous mme michèle rivasi vous
est la fondatrice de la criirad
cette mission de recherche indépendante
sur la radioactivité et puis en face de
vous et bien le professeur andré aurengo
où vous êtes chef du service de médecine
nucléaire à la pitié salpêtrière et vous
étiez vous avez été chargé par lé
gouvernement jospin de faire justement
une carte de la contamination en france
alors je sais pas qui démarre michèle
rivasi
qu'est-ce qu'il faut se dire des
conséquences pour la santé de ce fameux
survol de la france est maintenant 19
ans alors est-ce que les cancers ou pas
d'abord je vais voudrait dire que ça y
est maintenant il a fallu attendre 19
ans pour qu'on confirme bien que la
france a été contaminée par messure on
est sûr il ya un rapport d'experts qui a
été commanditée par la juge bertella
geffroy qui a dit effectivement il ya eu
mensonge d'état
on n'a pas informé la population
française du fait de qu'ils ont consommé
des aliments radioactifs discernement
selon qui est à l'origine de ce pan sont
suspects au professeur pellerin dit
toujours qu'il n'a jamais dit que le
nuage s'était arrêté à la frontière
oui mais par contre il n'a pas et former
les gens que dans certaines parties de
la france vous avez cité le sud-est il y
avait la corse et l'alsace sont à
prendre
il y avait des précautions à prendre
notamment ne pas consommer du lait
contaminé ne pas consommer des légumes à
larges feuilles de dire aux enfants de
pas jouer dehors faire les mesures
l'ipad lire ce qu'il fallait faire
exactement escalade dont des
conséquences alors des cancers notamment
de la thyroïde plus important
aujourd'hui à cause de ce nuage alors
le problème c'est justement il faut
quantifier
il y à des cancers de la thyroïde alors
à l'heure actuelle les chiffres mais on
n'a pas de registre national de cancer
la thyroïde en france
alors c'est dommage ça a été demandé à
plusieurs reprises par le dr fauconnier
encore ça a été demandé par la criirad
c'est de me demander par moi même quand
j'étais député on n'a toujours pas de
registre il avait au rendez vous pour
parler oui mais juste je voudrais me
manques il y avait encore un département
où il fallait absolument faire des
études épidémiologiques sur
l'augmentation de cancer la théorie à
l'heure actuelle les endocrinologues en
corse 10 on a plus de cancers en corse
que sur la métropole y en a pas d'études
fiables certaines scientifique sur la
question et professeur aurengo ya des
professeurs le professeur yvon graal
l'associé française d'énergie nucléaire
qui dicte lui que le cancer que le nuage
n'a provoqué aucun cancer
supplémentaires je pense que ce que divo
graal enfin que je que j'approuve 1
n'est pas l'opinion du monde râle ni la
mienne personnel je pense que c'est une
opinion qui est très largement partagée
par tous ceux qui s'occupent
effectivement de cancer et de cancers
thyroïdiens en particulier va pas lui en
vouloir
oui qui n'en avait pas eu en plus les
raisons sont très simples à les raisons
très simples les alors quand je parle de
ces médecins ce sont des isotopes is de
ce sont des endocrinologues c'est en
particulier la société française dans le
dos chronologie qui s'est largement
prononcé sur ce sujet qu'elles seront à
semer là dessus nous attend et je vais
je vais y venir les cancers de la
thyroïde ont augmenté c'est vrai ils ont
commencé à augmenter plus de dix ans
avant l'accident de tchernobyl
deuxièmement sur quelle base d'oie
attendait rien pas de registre et non
mais ya pas de registre on n'a pas
besoin écoutez je vous ai laissé parler
je vous ai pas interrompue mais donc
vous dire et après on n'y a pas de
registre ya quand même un certain nombre
de registres fiable il ya un certain
nombre de données qui sont fiables sur
le nombre de cancers de la thyroïde
convoi en france ce sont des données qui
permettent en particulier de suivre très
précisément l'évolution ces cancers la
deuxième chose c'est que cette
augmentation est visible dans tous les
pays
compris dans ceux qui n'ont pas été
touchées par l'accident par exemple au
canada ou aux états unis
la troisième raison qui est probablement
la plus importante c'est que cette
augmentation touche des adultes elle ne
touche pas les enfants alors vous dis
qu'effectivement il ya des registres ya
des registres en champagne ardenne et on
voit très bien que pour les enfants il
n'y a aucune modification or si c'était
l'accident de tchernobyl qui cause
l'augmentation des cancers ça causerait
l'augmentation chez les ans si j'ai bien
compris la surprise d'entendre
il ya eu plus de cancers mais c'est une
évolution naturelle due sans doute à
d'autres choses au montage et
socialement et au fait qu'il y a
beaucoup de micro cancer pour que l'on
ait conduit oise est aujourd'hui stage
vous donner un chiffre dans mon serval
ans le nombre de ces tout petits cancers
a été multiplié par 10 de réflexion la
sms le lobby nucléaire est-elle en
france que la vérité ne peut être fait
en la matière on est que les gens sont
passerait pas tellement confiance en
nous est-ce pour nous protéger d'un vent
de panique on nous a caché la vérité sur
les conséquences de ce nuage radioactif
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ce que du
professeur vous dites est allé cancer
même se faisait pas preuve on a fait
sauter un premier verrou qui est qui et
il ya eu des retombées de tchernobyl
mais non il ya un deuxième verrou à
faire sauter sur les conséquences un
millier sur les conséquences sanitaires
et moi je voudrais informer les français
là dessus ça fait 19 ans quand se
bagarrent pour qu'ils aient des
registres de cancer
il est anormal qu'en france on est que
seulement 9 registres de cancer et
notamment qu'on n'est même pas un
registre national de cancer la thyroïde
alors qu'on a le professeur galle mais
il faut pas oublier que le professeur
galle fait partie d'une association de
promotion du nucléaire
donc on les voyait devant le rayon graal
on est devant une chape de plomb qui est
de dire ya une augmentation de cancers
tne et c'est naturel or nous on dit
partout non nous les preuves ont une
vraie étude ethnologique encore sur la
crise que la course a été
particulièrement touchée pour réaliser
en fonction de ce registre là avec
monsieur haut-rhin govou pourrait dire à
l'abri non il ya eu et bagnolet
chaussures un goal professeur andrew
terminée est ce que vous êtes un as
suppôts du lobby nucléaire il vous êtes
là pour me dire qu'il ya pas eu de
conséquences alors qu' on a eu est-ce
que vous êtes favorable à ce qui est
effectivement une vraie enquête à tous
madame rivasi n'est pas la seule à
demander qu'il y ait des registres de
cancer en france et une demande qui est
formulée par tous les épidémies
6 il faut bel avait montré des cartes
tout à l'heure vous avez vu que la
contamination a été beaucoup plus forte
dans l'est que dans l'ouest alors
j'aimerais qu'on m'explique pourquoi
l'augmentation des cancers de la
thyroïde prédomine dans l'ouest et pas
dans l'est
mais si pas sur trois registres madame
bon proposer à de vraies enquêtes
épidémiologiques même pas s'il est
exécrable la responsabilité du nuage
dans cette affaire merci à tous les deux
merci beaucoup
partout maintenant pour new york et la
bourse de wall street on le sait où on
le devine les séances sont durs aussi
pour les mères alors les traders ne
savent plus quoi inventer pour se
détendre ils ont installé un ring juste
à côté des salles de côte de cotation
pascal golomer et tristan le braz